what's up buzz hey man how's it going
good we're gonna make this the last
question yeah so what do you got for me
tonight sweet uh i'd have a question for
you about uh
maybe what what's the best way to go
about meeting a girl for a long-term
relationship and uh by that i mean i can
go about it online or i can do it in
person and i feel like there's pros and
cons to both
but i want to hear your opinion on it
you know kind of where i want to invest
my time
the
best roi is online generally
right yeah you need to make the most
yeah absolutely i mean if you set up a
proper date like have you read my book
yeah absolutely actually well audiobook
but okay so there's a chapter in the
book that that tells you exactly what to
do i mean if you follow that that just
makes your life so much easier it's like
i talk about inbound marketing to my uh
coaching clients when it comes to
business where you want your customers
to come to you okay
if you have a proper online dating
profile with good photography you're
good at getting the number and setting
up the date and you've got game it's
very easy to have options right now
right i would say don't just do that as
you go about your day and you come
across an attractive woman that you dig
just walk up to her make a cold approach
you know see if you can open and get her
number and you know get a a date
uh yeah
it's not that hard just it's it's
putting in the repetitions right it's
like doing the work and putting in the
reps that's true okay cool so if i'm
setting up my online profile i mean what
would you recommend in terms of trying
to get pictures things like that i think
that's probably the weakest point that i
have personally
professional photography professional
photography exactly how i outlined in
the chapter so yeah you need to hire
someone to yeah you need the mystery
shot you need the group a friend shot
you need a good um like head shot like a
good smile you need one showing off you
know your physique like those would be
the main ones right but not like douchey
like i'm standing in the mirror doing a
mirror selfie
you want you know what a good example of
good photography is so if you go to
men's
sorry um jared can you drop your uh
instagram in the chat bro um i'm going
to give you jiren's
instagram it's basically the same
photographs that he uses for his dating
profile so i've heard you mentioned him
before so i never checked it out so
might as well dude you got to do the
work i mean you're asking me for the
advice i've provided the advice you
didn't check it out last time i'm gonna
get you check it out this time so if you
guys go and follow jiren scott
on instagram you'll see a really good
example of how to of of the kind of
photographs that you need that get women
to properly respond to you you can also
see chris uh moffett's as well
there's a reason why i tell these guys
you know that are watching right now
after the show go watch or go and go and
deal with moff and jiren on their show
it's kind of a companion show there are
a couple of guys from my community
they'll be on next monday with me
they're good dudes right like they know
what they're doing in fact i would argue
they're probably better at dealing with
online game because they're dealing with
it every single day right like they're
spinning a bunch of plates i got a bunch
of girls i'm in an ltr like i don't deal
with that [ __ ] anymore right
does it work it absolutely works i mean
they follow exactly what i do
what i have done and done in the past to
an actual t so right follow that and do
it but photography is probably
the most important component to online
game right i really yeah i'd have to
remember like women have all these
options they could sit here and do this
all day long and it's like there's
endless supplies of dudes so how do you
stand out with photography you have to
have good photographs she has to
basically look at it and go oh yeah i
want to be in that picture with that guy
with those people in that environment
right yeah and that's where the value
comes in right i mean if you're a
high-value guy you have interesting
friends you're captivating you do cool
[ __ ] you have some style you got good
photography
she's going to be doing this and she's
going to be like oh there's buzz
lightyear i'm going to swipe right on
that guy
hell yeah cool man and then so how do i
how would i uh check out their thing
afterwards like where is it on youtube
or uh stereo is the app so if you just
get the stereo app and you search for
moth m-o-f-f
they're on right after my show and they
do some call and stuff too okay cool man
i'll check it out all right
thanks hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you